flow Genome Project what we've
discovered when people want more flow in
their lives the number one thing we can
tell them is that there is a flow cycle
so the old idea about flow was there was
a binary it was like a light switch you
were in the zone or you were out of his
own what we now know is that flow is a
four part cycle you have to move through
all four parts of these cycle of the
cycle before you can return to the flow
state itself the neurobiology the flow
cycle the actual research came out of
herb Benson's work at Harvard he kind of
laid the foundation for it but what
we've discovered is at the front end of
the flow state there's a struggle phase
this is a loading phase you were loading
then overloading the brain with
information for a baseball player this
is learning to swing a bat at a ball for
a writer planning a new book this is
when you're doing interviews this is
when you're reading it's when you're
diagramming structure and things like
that it's very unpleasant as a general
rule so even though flow may be the most
desirable and pleasant state on earth
the actual flow cycle itself start with
a very unpleasant state known as
struggle from struggle you move into
release this literally means you want to
take your mind off the problem so what
happens in flow is we are trading
conscious processing which is slow has
very limited RAM right the working
memory can only hold about four items at
once and it's very energy inefficient
for subconscious processing which is
extremely fast very energy efficient and
has pretty much endless RAM so to do
that you have to move from struggle you
have to let stop thinking about what you
were trying to think about basically you
take your mind off the problem you go
for long walks gardening works very well
building models works very very well
Albert Einstein famously
used to row a boat into the middle of
Lake Geneva and stare at the clouds
right once you can take your mind off
the problem and will by the way one of
the only things that you can't do to
move through release is watch television
it actually changes your brainwaves in a
way that will block flow but once you
move from release there's actually
underneath the surface nor biologically
there's a global release of nitric oxide
which is a gaseous signalling molecule
it's found everywhere in the body this
flushes all the stress hormones out of
your system and replaces them kind of
feel-good performance enhancing neural
chemicals like dopamine and Amanda mine
and serotonin and endorphins which
underpin the flow state as well you're
in the flow state itself this is the
third stage of the struggle and on the
back end of the flow state there is
actually a recovery phase and this is
really really really critical so you go
from this amazing high flow to a very
deep low that shows up and recovery a
lot of this is that all those feel-good
neural chemicals have drained out of
your system it takes certain vitamins
and minerals and sunlight and things
like that to rebuild them so the
recovery phase on the back end of the
flow state is actually very very
unpleasant as well and if you really
want to hack flow you need to learn how
to struggle better and you need how to
learn how to recover better and one of
the most important things in recovery is
you have to you need some emotional
fortitude some grit you have to
basically hold on to your emotions not
get stressed out at the fact that you no
longer feel like Superman and the main
reason what two reasons for this is one
if you get too stressed out at feeling
low you're going to start producing
cortisol a little bit is fine too much
of it blocks the accelerated learning
that comes with flow so you'll actually
you'll get the short-term benefit of the
flow state itself but you won't get the
long-term benefit the accelerated
learning that you get in flow the other
problem is if you have to move from
recovery back into struggle you're
bummed out and no longer being in flow
during the recovery phase it's very hard
to get up for the difficult bite of
struggle that follows
you